working dogs has been in the family for
a very long time being all the time is
he you had to have good dogs all the
time and I've been lucky I've always had
some good working dogs with me all my
life now had some bad ones as well but
that's I used to same commands as my
father
we've got English commands are we lie
down write down and a [ __ ] up and we've
got Welsh commands dalla Mauro four so
four so four but it did if you've got a
good pitch that throws a good strain
which dark you given her a meeting you
don't have some little pups from that
strain the main aspect is in the beach
I'm convinced of that hopefully the next
generation my brother's two daughters
they are very keen although yeah very
young at the moment they're very keen to
follow in our footsteps
I think the eldest will come because I
remember my short two and a half years
old I was coming up that field and
commanding the dark and made two fingers
in mouth whistling and she was crying in
front next thing that I saw she was
putting two fingers in her mouth I'm
trying to whistle the dogs has been in
our family business for over sorry with
our two
nice is now I'm hoping that the darks
will keep our little business for
another century
you
[Music]
you